et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
gérard filoche porte parole de la gauche
démocratique et sociale bonsoir gérard
filoche à vos côtés jean marc flipo
porte-parole de debout la france bonsoir
jean marc gibeau merci d'être avec nous
alors donc après pasteur on le disait en
janvier sanofi maintenant clairement la
france est le seul pays des membres du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui n'a pas
son propre vaccin est ce qu'on peut
parler jean marc flipo d'échec
industriels
je sais pas si c'est un échec industriel
comme le disait très justement votre
votre reporter il ya des retards qui ne
se rattrape pas en l'occurrence c'était
effectivement trop tard mais moi ce que
je constate surtout c'est que les
objectifs de santé publique qui étaient
dévolues à ces laboratoires dans le par
le passé aujourd'hui s'efface devant
deux des logiques de marque de marché
stricto sensu je pense qu'effectivement
le le docteur adams gebreyesus qui est
directeur général de l' oms a dû tomber
de sa chaise lorsqu'il a entendu qu'il
n'y avait pas de besoins de santé
publique pour un vaccin arn messagers
alors on peut discuter de comment dire
de des effets secondaires de la rn
messager delà du temps nécessaire pour
pour en mesurer toutes les conséquences
m'enfin y'a quand même toute l'afrique
qui n'est pas mesurée qui n'est pas
vacciné pardon et est en mesure pas
encore les conséquences de cette absence
de vaccination sur ce continent voilà
donc c'est vraiment on est dans une
logique purement de marché
effectivement sanofi avec gsk développe
un vaccin
traditionnels ils vont rapporter le
marché enfin ils vont se positionner sur
un marché de la troisième dose qui est
tout simplement gigantesque puisque aux
états unis on ne parlera que de ça il
sera elle ne parle que de ça et j'ai pu
mais le pari que lé en france on en
parlera
avec insistance très bientôt donc là ils
vont remporter à forme de jackpot et
puis ils vont remporter aussi le jackpot
sur leur développement parce qu'ils ont
fait des travaux quand même sourire à un
messager et essayeront sont en train de
le réorienter vers la grippe saisonnière
puisqu'ils ont commencé les essais de
phase 1 donc en juin dernier qui sont
apparemment prometteur il la
problématique de la grippe saisonnière
c'est que le virus change tous les ans
et qui est donc un temps d'adaptation
lite est assez long entre le moment où
on développe le virus traite de vaccins
traditionnels et le moment où on livre
les les doses et si on arrive à
raccourcir ce qu'on arrive à raccourcir
ce délai et blanc sera plus efficace et
on pourra donc livré un vaccin beaucoup
plus efficace et ça c'est un immense
marché à l'échelle planétaire
je vous propose d'écouter l'une des
réactions politiques un nombreuses
évidemment depuis ce matin celle
d'esther benbassa sénatrice écologiste
paris
sanofi toujours en avance faire de la
recherche ou faire du fric parfois il
faut choisir le laboratoire français
arrêtent le développement de son pack
sein à arn messagers effectivement dans
la lignée de ce que vous venez de nous
dire jean marc chipeau alors c'est vrai
qu'on recontextualise tout d'abord
gérard filoche assure le diagnostic et
cet art est un petit peu stratégique
puisque sanofi dit bien voilà ça servira
à rien on sera trop nombreux sur le
marché autant se concentrer sur le le
rappel et avancer sur sur d'autres
secteurs sur le diagnostic qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
c'est pas une question de la nationalité
du vaccin c'est une question de la
cupidité les actionnaires
l'actionnariat visiblement de sanofi est
plus intéressé par l'ampleur de ses
profits maximum que par l'intérêt
général des humains c'est ça la question
fondamentale rappelez vous il ya même
pas combien six mois ils ont supprimé
400 postes 400 postes dans les domaines
de recherche et développement
rappelez-vous la photo de philippe
martinez devant sanofi les
manifestations des salariés on est dans
un pays où l'habitude de ne pas écouter
les salades en un pays où il n'y a pas
l'habitude d'écouter les syndicats eh
ben les syndicats et les salariés
avaient raison et en l'occurrence y
dénonçait davance ce qui dit des les
actionnaires et je répète c'est la
cupidité bras l'intérêt général et donc
ça pose toute la question de la
recherche en france ces trois ans qu'un
souvenir d'un témoignage de bruno canard
qu'était un chercheur du cnrs du cnrs à
marseille il expliqué la science ne
marche pas dans l'urgence et la réponse
immédiate dès 2008 2009 en france il
travaille est ce qu on habille russe est
depuis à la fois sarkozy hollande et
mâcon qui sont pas des gens qu'on fait
que se sont opposés à la finance ils ont
coupé les crédits les moyens de
rechercher pour la la recherche publique
et la recherche publique a été en mise à
bas également par la loi de
programmation de la recherche je me
souviens j'étais encore il ya un an en
novembre 2020 dru la rassemblent un
rassemblement université de censier où
il y avait des centaines des milliers de
gens qui les attentions va dans le mur
pourquoi ma chronique ou t-il pas ce
qu'ils savent il croit tout savoir sur
la loi de programmation de la recherche
il s'est trompé de a à z la recherche
publique
ces crédits les ont eues en sanofi mais
peut-être certainement vous allez nous
dire puisque ça va être l'objet de débat
on va continuer à poursuivre évidemment
sur sur les causes et mais justement
sanofi a bénéficié et c'est bien l'objet
des critiques je vais vous redonner la
parole vous inquiétez pas 150 millions
d'euros sous forme justement de crédit
impôt recherche ou sous la forme du cicr
le fameux crédit impôt compétitivité
emploi
clairement jean-marc chypre va redonner
la parole à gérard filoche évidemment
qui trépigne sur ce thème c'est de
l'argent mal investi ou investit trop
tard
qui est investi
accor au tac rencontre temps je sais pas
peut-être trop tard mais c'est surtout
un partenariat quelque chose qui s'est
cassé dans le dans l'articulation de la
recherche française lorsque l'épidémie
de coronavirus est arrivé donald trump
aux états unis a développé un lancer une
opération qui s'appelait war speed et
cette opération a porté sur 11 millions
de dollars sa femme après 1,9 milliard
et demi d'euros pour l'ensemble de
l'union européenne en avait que deux
milliards d'euros qui était qui étaient
débloqués donc on voit bien déjà il ya
un immense décalage en termes de en
termes de volume d'argent investies
ensuite comme le disait monsieur filoche
et je vais vous surprendre je suis
d'accord avec lui la recherche la
recherche médicale et s'effectue comme
la recherche d'ailleurs sur le temps
long et effectivement le
l'état a le devoir de a traversé le
notamment cnrs pas de lancer des
recherches
sur des maladies en plus de celles qui
ne sont pas rentables lorsqu'une
recherche sur une maladie qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas rentable on le
voit les coronavirus ça peut devenir
très rentable demeure donc il ya de
nouveaux partenariats on ne va pas
revenir à la recherche étatique
gaullienne des années soixante dix on a
basculé dans un autre monde un monde
vraiment l'argent est roi où les marchés
commandes mais par contre il former des
partenariats et il surtout avoir des
retours sur investissement lorsque
l'état reste il faut qu ils de retour
sur investissement le crédit impôt
recherche c'est très bien mais en france
on a en a l'habitude d'empêcher les gens
au départ dans des créations de de
biotech par exemple on les empêche de
deux recherchés on leur met des charges
à peu partout sur les épaules et pia
point l'armé des béquilles pour pour
développer la recherche le crédit impôt
recherche
c'est ça les start up française les
biotech française les medtechs
françaises qui sont qui sont innovantes
qui sont qui sont nombreuses ont besoin
d'avoir d'avoir un accès à la recherche
fondamentale et atic ont besoin d'avoir
un archet un accès aux financements
c'est vraiment par là qu'on pêche
développer une molécule ses dix ans de
travail et c'est environ un milliard
d'euros donc il faut ré accompagner nos
pépites françaises il faut ensuite
empêcher qu'elle ne tombe effectivement
sous la coupe d'entreprises
principalement américaines qui fondent
de la prédation scientifique
effectivement gérard filoche on imagine
que vous êtes d'accord avec jean marc
flipo c'est quelque chose qu'on a vu
tout au long de cette pandémie des
petites entreprises qui n'étaient pas
subventionner toujours et soutenu
suffisamment par l'état et qui trouvait
les subventions souvent ailleurs à
l'étranger notamment du royaume uni
voire des états unis
même j'étais en train de vous le dire
sous sarkozy il est très bien pour
rechercher passé de 1,5 milliard 6
milliards soit deux fois le budget du
cnrs c'est à dire que la recherche
publique a été spolié aux bénéfices la
recherche privée et la recherche privée
elle n'agit pas sur le long terme elle
n'agit pas selon l'intérêt général elle
agit selon des marges de profits et les
décisions des actionnaires
c'est pour ça qu'il faut donner la
priorité à la recherche publique qu'il
faut donner l'argent pour le temps long
qu'il faut donner l'argent à ceux qui
sont préoccupés l'intérêt général et
qu'il faut pas le donner aux cupids
actionnaires qui dirige sanofi et qui
supprime des emplois pour augmenter
leurs marges bénéficiaires
c'est aussi simple que ça ce à quoi nous
assistons et quand je disais c'est la
faute à mâcon ce n'est pas à lui
seulement puisque avant sarkozy et
hollande ne pas privilégier la recherche
publique puisque la mode est à donner au
privé aux start up au lieu de donner à
la recherche d'eau font et à tous les
services qui vont avec c'est quand même
un choix fondamental mâcon dans ses
choix budgétaires
il se rattrape jamais les erreurs non
plus quand on enlève là cherche public
quand on enlève aux hôpitaux quand on
enlève sécurité sociale quand on enlève
aux services publics dans leur ensemble
et bien en un résultat aussi dérisoire
c'est là où on a mis l'argent chez
sanofi eh bien ça vous classe dans les
doigts et bien là on a mis l'argent
c'est sanofi bien ne font pas ce qui se
fait dans d'autres pays ce qui fonde
d'ailleurs que mâcon est pire que les
dirigeants capitalistes des autres pays
non ses choix et dans ses
investissements et qu'il a aggravé sa
depuis qu'il est là puisque même en
cours d'année là il vient de d'appuyer
la diminution de crédit de publication
et et là je gardais des syndicalistes
qui vous disent tous les jours de façon
plus compétentes que moi et qui
n'accepte pas et comme ce pouvoir
n'entend rien des corps intermédiaires
des salariés des syndicats de ceux qui
sont publiques et bien à chaque fois il
fait la même erreur et on a un journal
télévisé comme ce soir madame où on vous
dira alors qu'est ce qui se passe avec
sanofi c'est un échec français mais il
n'y a pas de surprise
nous savions nous l'avions dit fallait
nous entende faut changer le
gouvernement pourrait que ce soit des
gens qui vous l'ont dit attends qui
gouvernent et qui puissent planifier
maintenant
en tout cas ça donne et certaines idées
notamment à emilie carillon la députée
les nouveaux démocrates de la meuse qui
propose justement de se servir du fameux
c'est hier pour favoriser la
relocalisation écouter
cet amendement j'aurais pu la paix
l'amant non sanofi conditionner le
crédit impôt recherche à la
relocalisation des chaînes de production
balayé sanofi continue à toucher le
crédit d'impôt recherche abandonne la
recherche sur le vaccin arn stop à
l'argent public déversés sans
contrepartie jean marc flipo c'est un
début de piste conditionné justement à
la relocalisation
écoutez moi je suis ravi que toute la
france se convertissent au aux idées
nicolas dupont aignan est debout la
france
nous n'avons eu de cesse de répéter cela
depuis au moins depuis 2012 c'est
merveilleux oui je trouve que nicolas
dupont aignan se présente à la
présidentielle et que dans son programme
est effectivement un indic haine qui
concerne la relocalisation de la
production des principes actifs et des
médicaments et que pour accéder à
remboursement par la sécurité sociale
parce que sont les français qui payent
il ya l'aspect financement de la
recherche mais après vous avez les
français qui doivent payer les
médicaments qui doivent payer les
vaccins via leurs cotisations sociales
eh bien on veut conditionner
effectivement le remboursement de ses
magasins de ces médicaments et de ses
principes actifs à la production sur le
sol national à hauteur de 50% au moins
pour les pour les médicaments qui vont à
des remboursements supérieur à 20
millions d'euros et ça effectivement
c'est quelque chose de concret qui peut
faire changer qui va faire changer les
mentalités 1 gérard filoche sur wii
alesi
jaune
oui si vous donnez à réduire le problème
comme ça moi aussi je suis candidat à la
présidentielle parrainé mois à la
primaire populaire et je vous dirai des
choses bien plus complète que ce que
vous venez de dire parce que moi je
m'appuie sur les salariés les syndicats
et ce qui attend publiquement ont milité
manifester fait grève pour que ce que
nous voyons ce soir n'arrive pas et je
vous ai pas beaucoup vu unis dont les
grèves ni dans les manfestations me dont
les soldats étaient des salariés nous
ait pas beaucoup vu à temps défendre le
public contre le privé j'ai plutôt
l'import l'intérêt que l'impact d'idées
que vous faites le contraire alors si
vous réduisez une autre des battoirs à
une candidature nous vous jure que je
serai meilleur en défense des salariés
que votre dupont aignan je vous jure que
ce sera beaucoup plus attentifs au
service public et à l'ensemble de la
recherche publique parce que moi les
choix que je veux faire ce pâté sont
évidemment très différent des veaux et
de tous ceux qui défendent le
capitalisme d'une banque nationale ou
pas et donc je suis moi pour la priorité
aux salariés pour les écouter les
entends les arbres ils ont des comités
dont des syndicats et ils ont eu raison
plus lucidement que les dirigeants de
sanofi plus lucidement que les
actionnaires de sanofi est donc
maintenant faut faire des choix stop à
l'argent et à la cupidité oui au service
public oui à la défense de l'intérêt des
humains oui à l écoute des salariés et
si vous m'avez amenée à dire ça c'est
parce que c'est finalement quelque part
la question essentielle pour cause est
débarrassé de mâcon aujourd'hui il a
failli en tournée pas l on n'avait pas
de masque on n'avait pas de lit on
n'avait pas de sens
on as été donné aux gens de se poser on
a bien compris le message je vous
l'avais répété plusieurs fois on a
compris voilà c'était le service public
avant tout mais eux ce que nous disait
jean marc flipo tout à l'heure donald
trump est investi des milliards c'était
une vraie force de guerre il est entré
en guerre contre ce virus il a investi
des milliards le vaccin est sorti en
novembre
annoncé d'ailleurs au lendemain de la
présidentielle et la victoire de joe
biden pourtant on vous n'êtes pas un
grand défenseur du libéralisme façon
trump et ça a marché là bas quelle
différence avec la france
vit en france le salaire moyen des
chercheurs et 63 % du salaire de l' ocde
je vous dis en france ils ont adopté un
système que tellement controversé parce
qu'il n'est pas par projet donc il est
il est pas une recherche générale
fondamental c'est un système qui est
orienté son profit sur un point donné et
donc la france souffre des choix
gouvernementaux qui ont été faits et je
vous répète que c'est intimement liée à
la politique gouvernementale et donc
voilà qu'est ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise de plus la france entière
selon le cas soit aujourd'hui quand on
vous dit a pas de box en france s est
pas le problème du vaccin en fait c'est
le problème du capitalisme et de ceux
qui en france se soumettre aux discours
desiderata internationaux des trusts
pharmaceutiques dont sanofi jean marc
flipo le salaire des chercheurs ça aussi
l'inde est l'une des clés du problème
aujourd'hui et de cet échec
oui évidemment il ya un énorme problème
sur le salaire des chercheurs sur le
salaire des universités enfin lire tout
un tout un chantier enfin sur certains
points je veux pas je peux faire adhérer
le fil au chat debout la france mais je
pense qu'un certain nombre de points sur
lesquels on peut effectivement se
rejoindre mais si vous voulez
au delà de ça c'est tout c'est tout
l'articulation vraiment entre la
recherche publique fondamentale temps
long effectivement la recherche la
recherche fondamentale c'est quoi c'est
rechercher en médecine par exemple des
molécules dont on ne sait pas s'ils
auront un jour une utilité et ça il n'ya
pas effectivement il ya très peu
d'entreprises privées qui le font ou
alors elles délèguent ça maintenant à dr
debiotech quelle qu'elles vont absorber
tout de suite ensuite tout de suite
derrière pour faire du profit mais on a
besoin aujourd'hui le monde et est
confronté à de plus en plus de vagues
épidémiques
il ya délit at-il pas mal de danger qui
guette la planète on a besoin
effectivement de rebâtir un pôle de
recherche fondamentale en france et qui
va tirer ensuite l'industrie derrière
qui va nous permettre nous aussi d'avoir
demain des vaccins sur deux contre
d'autres maladies la lutte contre le
cancer et pense à ça et est d'un enjeu
mondial fondamentale on a besoin de
vraiment se se mobiliser là dessus si
beaucoup à tous les deux jean marc j
pour gérard filoche d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france